welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka Zack spoiler
and this video were breaking down the
Snyder cut it's been long thought that
the original and intended vision of the
director would never see the light of
day but yesterday a die-hard DC fans
everywhere got some incredible news that
is that the Snyder cut will be released
on HBO max in 2021 what exactly is the
cut and what changes in extras can we
expect well throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down everything you
need to know about the entire plot of
the movie from start to finish this is
the most extensive and in-depth
breakdown I've ever made on the piece
and it should pretty much cover the
majority of the movie now as of the
announcement we do know that there may
be some additional dialogue and scenes
added however this should pretty much
cover 90% of the movie obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here itself you
don't want any of the big surprises
potentially ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now now if
you're still here make sure you
subscribe to the channel as we do videos
like this every day and please drop a
thumbs up if you enjoy the content
without the way thank you for clicking
this now sit back relax and Hale Snyder
oh okay so up top we have to talk about
one of the Snyder cuts biggest
differences that is the entire score of
the film originally the piece was going
to be using the majority of hands image
original score for a Man of Steel in
Batman V Superman additions for this
such as a dark side theme would come
from junkie XL who had collaborated on
the aforementioned movies with Zimmer
this would allow the piece to feel more
in line with the other DC EU entries
that preceded it and in my opinion the
score would have fit the characters
better actually bought both the Man of
Steel and BBS soundtrack and was gutted
when they weren't in Justice League this
is because at the last minute Warner
Brothers decided to fire jxl and they
brought on board Danny Elfman Elfman of
course created the incredible Batman 89
theme however I didn't really feel like
it slotted in that well with the vision
that Snyder and Whedon had created due
to being brought in with very little
time Elfman had to reuse his older
themes as well as the John Williams
Superman one and you can tell it just
all
feels underdeveloped another big
difference is the film's length Warner
Brothers mandated a two-hour runtime for
Joss Whedon who was forced to pretty
much cut the movie in half originally it
was going to be three and a half hours
long however rumors are now circulating
that it's actually closer to four now
Whedon is getting a love-hate in the
wake of the announcements yesterday but
I actually don't blame him for any of
the things that happened it was Warner
Brothers who decided to change the
direction and he was brought on board in
the middle of the project had to rewrite
most of the script reshoot about 70% of
the movie edit it and also oversee the
CGI in a very short timeframe I can't
imagine how stressful this would have
been and he's definitely not the bad guy
in this as for how it will be released
we don't know if it's gonna be a 4-hour
film or if it's gonna be split into six
episodes I would lean more towards the
latter as at guess an HBO max trial
signup will last about a week they won't
sign up to their subscription service to
last at least one month they will do six
episodes released weekly this will mean
that people pay for at least one month
in order to watch it as its full release
period will be over the space of six
weeks that might turn out to be untrue
but yeah that's just how I'd imagine it
going forward as for the plot itself
unlike the theatrical release the film
didn't open on terrible cellphone
footage of the worst CGI blunder in
movie history so in the Schneider Kerr
Superman's phases no more it's gone it's
finally over
instead Justice League part 1 as it was
due to be called because the film was
originally meant to have a second part
to it began with the invasion of Earth
this was told to Bruce in a story by
Diana but in the original vision it was
supposed to open the film similar to the
Fellowship of the Rings we would see
that Darkseid was heading up the
invasion and that he not Steppenwolf was
leading the forces this has been shown
in several of the images from Zack
Sphero account and it really
kick-started the movie in a big bad way
here we saw much more of the battle with
Ares and Zeus which allowed the piece to
be tied together with Wonder Woman May
for a more complete DCU darkside was
defeated and Steppenwolf was banished
and the movie would center around him
trying to win favor with Darkseid after
their crushing defeat
as for Steppenwolf himself his design
was completely different
Steppenwolf was revealed to be a
relative of Darkseid and he looked more
in line with the design from Batman V
Superman rather than what would happen
if the marshmallow man hit the gym the
mother boxes themselves were too to take
on a far more distinctive role and they
would be like living entities rather
than just plot devices the three boxes
were meant to represent fear alienation
and doubt these are the main emotions
which the planet was feeling at the time
due to the death of Superman the general
despair were earth helped to power them
and this was when we got the line from
the trailer there are no protectors here
no Lantern no Kryptonian Steppenwolf was
going to use these devices to overwhelm
the planet and this would set up an
anti-life equation which would pay off
in other movies from here we jump to the
present to see a bearded Bruce Wayne
searching for Aquaman the opening was
far longer than the version that we got
in the theatrical release and it was
meant to mirror Batman Begins now one
thing that this scene massively improves
on is that it sorts out the continuity
error of Bruce fighting a criminal on
the rooftop clean shaven and then having
a full beard in the next scene in the
theatrical cut it either meant he was
wearing a face warmer or could grow a
full beard in six hours which didn't
make sense
Bruce would then meet with Aquaman and
exposit the dialogue that we saw in the
original teaser trailer this is when he
also says I hear you can talk to fish
Aquaman would reject Bruce and he would
shave on the plane and go back to Gotham
to continue being a vigilante we would
actually see him fighting criminals
there isn't a scene on the rooftop as
this was shot by Whedon there's also no
parademon fight and instead Bruce finds
out about them from Lex Luthor's journal
he collected this after the events of
Batman V Superman and Jesse Eisenberg
did stay that many of his scenes were
cut apparently Bruce at one point even
returns to Arkham to interrogate him
over what he meant over the Bell being
rung this would drive him to escape and
would of course sell the post-credits
scene at the same time Wonder Woman
tackles the suicide bombers in London
however unlike the theatrical cut she
fails to stop a secondary explosion this
is something that was also present in
early trailers while sera no casualties
she still harbors a lot of the blame and
the film takes on a darker tone we are
then introduced to Barry Allen through
his saving of iris in it he speeds over
to her at SuperSpeed and grabs around
the throat and then chokeslam Z he saves
her and iris was originally going to be
played by Kersey Clemens but she was cut
entirely from the film from here we go
to the Daily Planet
and Martha and Louis discuss Clark's
death before Martha announces that she's
being evicted we have some images of
this and it looked like it would have
been a lot better than the terrible
alien scene that ended up in the final
cut louis visits heroes park as we saw
in the theory cool opening and here we
get the full sequence involving former
jimmy olsen actor mark McClure who
portrayed a cop and brought Lois coffee
routinely on a way to the memorial this
was a cameo for the actor who played
Olsen in the Christopher Reeves films
from here we get a much more fleshed out
origin story for cyborg we witness his
life as a football star and the
horrifying car crash that killed his
mother and critically injured him there
was also a sequence in which Victor
stone played and won a football game for
Gotham City University this would end up
impressing his mother Eleanor stone and
after the game Victor got angry that his
father didn't come to the match and
during the car ride home
this spills over causes an argument and
his mother crashes the car this
instantly kills her and we then
witnesses revival by Silas stone using a
mother box as seen in Batman V Superman
dawn of Justice but this time from the
angle of the scene happening rather than
just on a screen shown in the original
trailers the film then moves to Bruce
and Diana discussing the rejection of
Aquaman in the Batcave at the Daily
Planet
Lois plays a much more vital role she
discovers how the parademon kidnappings
are related and cyborg intercepts this
knowledge deciding what to do we follow
the character easily learns to fly and
control his powers the metal man
realizes that he can control the entire
nuclear arsenal of the world
however he fears for his humanity and
decides to step away after his father is
taken by parademons he goes to the
window and looks up to see where they
may have taken him off to there was also
a cutscene that involved Victor hiding
the mother box from a para demon and
discovering his arm cannon in the
process the film then reverts back to
the theatrical release with Steppenwolf
stealing the first mother box from the
Amazons the Amazonian send a warning to
Diana and she rejoins Bruce to discuss
the villain she informs him of the first
time he invaded the planet which has cut
much shorter as it was shown at the
beginning bruce seeks out Mary and Diana
begins a quest to find cyborg in
Atlantis Steppenwolf attacks this time
however he's joined by parademons which
distract Aquaman and the villain is able
to attain the box the fight is much
longer and has the Atlanteans realizing
there's an alien threat Willem Dafoe not
Meera discusses Steppenwolf with Aquaman
and instills his duty to track down the
box this is tied in more with the actors
lighter appearance in the Aquaman solo
movie and made for a better setup with
his character gaining much more
importance here the team then assemble
and venture into Gotham Harbor to take
down Steppenwolf the action scene plays
out much the same with extended dialogue
and more conflict from cyborg as he
struggles to control his power the
battle ends at a stalemate but the team
begins to come together pun intended as
they discussed the pros and cons of
bringing back Superman Lois wakes up
from a nightmare and reminisces over the
good times that she had with clock this
was a scene that was added to the
opening montage song but is far longer
here we flashback to the Batcave and
Bruce studies Superman's costume as
cyborg discovers the origins of the
mother box through virtual reality he's
able to investigate its history at the
hands of the Nazis in World War 2 which
slightly reckons the discovery of it in
the deleted scenes of Wonder Woman he
then reveals to the Justice League that
Silas stone is his father and he
explains that the mother box rearranges
matter at the will of its master which
explains how Steppenwolf is able to
terraform the planet the group argues
back and forth over whether to revive
Superman much as we saw in the
theatrical cut but eventually they agree
to go to the Kryptonian ship the movie
explains that Superman is able to be
revived without trying
forming him into another doomsday
because of the growth codex inside him
that prevents his cells from
destabilizing after this Superman is
revived in the commencing battle that
the Man of Steel has with the remaining
League devastates heroes Park this fight
takes place at night and involves the
military who are firing at Superman due
to his confusion after the revival
apparently Superman was not going to say
a single line in this entire sequence
and we wouldn't get there the tomy you
didn't say like that but Batman did
that's my Batman impression anyway Lois
Lane who is passing at the time hears
this and runs to the confrontation to
save Clark from killing Batman similar
to how she did in the Martha scene of
BBS this is where we would also see
cyborg telling the police officers that
they should probably move Clark takes
Lois and then leaves this is when
Steppenwolf comes down and goes to take
the mother box from STAR Labs so now the
Justice League didn't just leave it
lying around in a car park the league
fought with Steppenwolf in the labs and
Silas stone actually died in the scene
which completely tore them apart cyborg
will be haunted in a simulation by his
mother father and the ghost of the man
he used to be this made him even more
torn over whether he was truly a man or
if he was now just a machine
anyway Clark and Lois arrived at the
farm and discussed their engagement this
scene was shown in trailers but cut down
for the theatrical releases strick
runtime of two hours but it added a lot
more character development now did the
movie need this scene man I think what
we got was enough but it's always nice
seeing Clark and Lois talking about
their relationship that was kind of
always the heart of Man of Steel mbbs so
I don't know why it was removed we then
joined the league at the Batcave who
discussed their defeat whilst alfred
humorously mocks them in his sarcastic
brash tone that everyone on YouTube
loves to hear this scene was extended
and it really fleshed out that Diana
should be the leader of the league even
if she disagrees with this position
overall it would have built more
camaraderie and gave motive to Batman's
suicide mission in the final act the
league would then embark on their
journey to take down Steppenwolf and we
would see a much gritty a moment in
which Batman arms of the other members
awkward
conversation is less humorous and he
mutters honestly I think we're all gonna
die
which is replaced with it I don't want
to die in the final version this was a
lot longer scene in which cyborg laid
out the strategy and the team really
bonded before they went into what could
be their last day on earth
Superman journeys to the ship for a suit
he retrieves as a blue and red one but
there's also a nod to the black one this
kinda shows that he wants to embody hope
and is no longer going down a darker
path and then he goes to visit Alfred to
discover the leaks plans Batman blaming
himself for Superman decides to become
bait and as he heads off on his suicide
mission the other leaguers tried to
dissuade and then help him
the final battle plays out much in the
same way that it doesn't at the Oracle
release why about when separating the
mother boxes
cyborg gets a glimpse at the nightmare
vision that batman hadn't bbs and he
also witnesses Darkseid this shows what
would happen if the unity was complete
the vision shows the nightmare world
from Batman V Superman and Darkseid
makes an appearance this was meant to
also complete the arc of Batman V
Superman so we finally had some closure
on that scene the team of course defeats
Steppenwolf but one no woman actually
beheads him as he goes into the boom
tube we see the other side of this where
his head rolls out and on apocalypse
Darkseid stops it with his boot teasing
the villain for the next film he sees
the league through the pool and they see
him and this sets up their rivalry to
come now for the end of the film we get
a much longer one in which Barry gains a
job at a crime lab in addition to this
he is too working on the cosmic
treadmill which explains how he was able
to travel through time in Batman V
Superman mera travels to land to bring
Aquaman back to Atlantis where he
belongs and she gets kicked off of
Aquaman 2 because it should a do he's
coming back other states that he's going
to see his father Thomas curry and his
story would have been picked up again in
the Aquaman film which would nicely
continue from this moment Bruce awakens
at night to be greeted by the Green
Lantern and Martian Manhunter Green
Lantern has arrived on earth after
hearing of the attack on the planet and
it would be revealed that general
Swanwick was actually Martian Manhunter
this would have obviously said what was
the kur
to confirm Green Lantern Corps movie but
that seems to have died along with the
ending of this scene you then cut to
Diana exploring ancient caves and trying
to unearth the meaning behind Darkseid
and the war that would be coming in
Justice League part two you got an
awesome cave wall painting of Darkseid
and this looked like a big tease for
what was to come down the line we then
got the Deathstroke post-credit scene
which ended the film and that's the
entire cut obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on it so make sure you
leave them below if you liked this video
then please give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to check out a breakdown of
some of the insane details in Iron Man
that only pay off after you watch the
entire MCU you wanna come chat to us
after the video make sure you follow us
on twitter at heavy spoilers or head
over to my discord server which is gonna
be linked in the description below we're
also giving away a free copy of the
Marvel phase 3 part 2 boxer on blu-ray
which contains Black Panther infinity
war endgame Captain Marvel and more and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning it's like the video
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the snider
cut in the comments section below the
winners gonna be chosen at random on the
15th of June and the cell be shipped out
from the intro ever gets the prize so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]